LIES, LIES.
WE'VE GOT TO GO.
MY NEXT GUEST IS AN AMERICAN
MUSLIM DOCTOR.
SHE SAYS CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR IS
AN EMBARRASSMENT AND A DISGRACE
TO THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MEMBER OF
THE COUNCIL ON FOREIGN RELATIONS
AND A COUNSELOR AT THE USC SHOWA
FOUNDATION.
DOCTOR, YOU ALSO SAY THAT OMAR
IS NOT THE VICTIM.
SHE PORTRAYED HERSELF TO BE.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
WHY'S THAT?
>> IT'S DIABOLICAL THAT SHE
COMMITS YET ANOTHER VIOLENT
AGAINST THE FAMILIES OF
SURVIVORS OF 9/11 AND THE
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF 9/11.
FOREMOST I AM A PHYSICIAN WHO
TAKES CARE OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SURVIVED OR HAD DISEASES
COMPLICATED BY THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER ATTACK.
THAT WAS DEVASTATING REMARKS
THAT I HEARD WHILE I WAS IN
AFRICA IN RWANDA COMMEMORATING A
GENOCIDE THERE.
SHE IS DEPICTING IN THIS
DIMINISHMENT WHAT I WOULD
DESCRIBE AS A PROFOUND DENIAL OF
9/11.
AS YOU KNOW, AT WORK A LOT WITH
ANTI-SEMITISM, AND IT REMINDS ME
OF THE MENTALITY OF HOLOCAUST
DENIERS OR, AS WE'VE SEEN IN
RWANDA, SOMEONE DENIED THE
GENOCIDE THEY ARE TOO.
THIS DENIAL RAISES IN ME A
COUPLE QUESTIONS.
DOES SHE REALLY THINK 9/11 WAS
NOT AN ISLAMIST JIHADIST ATTACK
WHICH CAME FROM WITHIN THE
MUSLIM FOLD.
THE KORAN TELLS US, ISLAM TELLS
US, WE MUST BE STRICT AND
OBSERVING JUSTICE, EVEN IF IT
MEANS BEARING WITNESS AGAINST
OURSELVES, AGAINST OUR KIN.
IT TELLS US WE HAVE TO DO THAT
WITH IMPARTIALITY.
WE CANNOT BE BIASED.
IF WE HAVE CERTAIN PREJUDICES.
SHE HARBORS PREJUDICES.
SHE DIMINISHED THE WORST ATTACK
ON THIS COUNTRY SINCE
PEARL HARBOR AND SHE DOES AN
ASSAULT ON MY PATIENTS, ALL
FAMILIES WHO ARE GRIEVING FOR
THEIR SURVIVORS.
IT'S DESPICABLE.
WORSE IS THAT OPPONENTS, WHEN
THEY'RE IN HER PARTY ARE NOT ARE
SHIELDING HER FROM THE KIND OF
CRITICISM SHE DESERVES.
>> Laura: DR. QANTA AHMED,
WERE GOING TO HAVE AN ENTIRE HOU
WERE GOING TO HAVE AN ENTIRE HOR
WERE GOING TO HAVE AN ENTIRE HOO
WERE GOING TO HAVE AN ENTIRE HON
JUST THE CONVERSATION OF ISLAM
AND THE WORLD TODAY, ESPECIALLY
ITS ROLE IN AMERICA.
THIS CONVERSATION SHOULD FOCUS
ON THE FACTS JUST LAID OUT A
WHOLE BUNCH OF THEM.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
WITH US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, LAURA, AND IF I
CAN SAY THIS OBSERVATION OF
DENYING 9/11 WAS MADE TO ME WHEN